you guys really want to see more of
these
all right
all right well in this week's episode I
actually didn't film any of me building
the actual props and I apologize for
that I was feeling ill under the weather
and the day when I had to come in to
build it so I just came in real quick
built the stuff and got out of here I'm
just gonna kind of talk about the
perhaps that I built for this week's
episode and really in all honesty was a
pretty light episode there was only two
real props that I had a bill for this
week's show as you can see I got another
list there Doug sent out but before he
sent it out about a day or two before he
sent the script out I think he was like
he's still working on the script he
called me and he's like we're doing
Cinderella old versus new I need you to
build me a giant gun that I can strap to
my crotch that I'm gonna call Janice
injustice so I was like obviously
immediately I can I started thinking
about what I wanted to do and how I
wanted to build it and I knew I was
gonna have to make it out of very
lightweight materials originally I was
kind of thinking I'm just gonna build it
out of cardboard tubing and you know
mostly cardboard itself so it's
lightweight and it could be supported
with just a belt around his waist
however as I said I wasn't feeling too
well when I came in that day so I really
didn't feel like building anything from
scratch so I just started pulling pieces
off the shelves of things I had lying
around that could quickly slept together
and make this prop and still make it
look good enough to wear you know it
looks like a gun and it can be worn on
your crotch so what resulted was Johnson
justice it's already kind of falling
apart as you can see wasn't built to
last but I'll kind of go with a little
breakdown of all the parts that I use to
assemble this crotch gun some of you
might have already recognized right off
the bat
the end or the extension on the barrel
here is blade sword from last week's
episode
it's just that PVC I didn't even paint
it's still painted the same black with
some of the highlighting on it and then
the grip a piece of tubing that I used
that was on there as just glued to the
bottom of the gun there yeah it's just
being held on with a piece of dowel rod
with some tape around it and some foam
they kind of hold it into place the
barrel itself is off of a nerf gun I've
got a bin back there full of nerf gun
parts so I just grabbed that and glued
it to a piece of PVC and the PVC pipe
I had a threaded fitting for the end of
it and I have a flange so I could just
screw the fitting right to the flange
and then bolted the flange to this piece
of MDF board which I cut in the shape of
the crotch and attached the belt so that
he can strap it on and do whatever he
does the outer covering to kind of cover
up the obvious big plastic PVC tube is
just a piece of gutter extension it's
just a piece of plastic that you can buy
at Home Depot for your gutters little
extension piece they kind of give your
gutter an extra like you know two or
three feet or something like that it was
already painted I already used it for
something else so I just cut it down and
cut the notches in both sides that I
could feed the bullets into like that
and the bullets are just Halloween store
or costume store bullets that you can
purchase at like Party City or something
like that I have a whole bin full of
them I just took off the as many as I
needed and wrapped it around the lid of
a spray paint bottle spray paint can't
just had a bunch of discarded lids lying
around so I just popped one of those off
glue the bullets to it and glued the
bullets
then to the gun that's about it all the
pieces were actually already kind of
painted I don't think I think I just had
to touch up the paint real quick but
essentially that was it kind of threw it
together probably in about two hours and
my mind was gonna be a little different
the only thing that kind of initially
when he told me what I wanted what
initially what he told me that he needed
it I knew I was gonna have the the
double drum of machine-gun bullets
attached that was the the only thing
that kind of remained from my initial
thought of how I was gonna build it but
ultimately came together and quite often
that's kind of how it goes the other
proud that we needed for this episode
was a landmine for devil boner to step
on blow up again
I wasn't feeling well I was kind of like
I don't care I just need something that
already exists Barney came in to give me
a hand it's kind of acquiring some of
the other props and items or really was
this kind of finding stuff we'd had to
Rastafarian hats we had there already in
our hat been over there and then we
needed a CD that had like a print CD the
landmine very simply was just like let's
just grab a paper plate from our kitchen
yeah you kind of fell apart since
filming but yeah this it's a paper plate
that I cut the brim off of and spray
painted black with a little bit of grey
and stuff and the button or whatever you
want to call it on the top there was
just a cap off of a yeah it's just the
cap off of like a squeeze pouch like
those kind of fruit on the go kind of
squeeze pouches just the cap off one of
those and a little piece of PVC tubing
there's glue to the top glue down there
then finally I just glued a bunch of
other random pieces of plastic that I
had lying around to the top of it to
kind of give it some texture and that
was it that was all we really did was I
really only took like minutes to
construct so I'm a light episode this
week not a lot of stuff to show you
yeah and Johnson justice is kind of an
interesting problem so I figured I would
at least talk about the building process
for that particular problem I just want
to start off by saying thank you to the
outpouring of support we got from the
first episode I really appreciate it I
was kind of overwhelmed actually by how
much you guys really enjoyed the show
and the prospect of it becoming a show
so we're going to make it a show and I'm
gonna try and make it as interesting as
possible if you guys are interested in
just seeing me build stuff for the
nostalgia critic episodes we I can
continue to do that if you guys are also
interested in seeing me build other
props for other projects or just for fun
we can do that too yeah by all means let
me know in the comments and I'll try and
continue to build cool stuff and make it
entertaining to watch so thanks so much
again for all the support it was really
kind of blown away by how much you guys
really liked the show and really wanted
to see more so tune in and see you next
time